Film Courage: Tom, one of your scripts that
you had from the 2006 era on ended up getting
you a manager?
Is that right?
Tom Oesch, Director of DANGER ONE:
Yes, that was is 2012.
So it was a few years into making stuff.
The way I got the managers…well I probably
have to rewind, I went to USC Film School.
In film school (any film school) you make
a lot of friends and they are the ones that
help you make stuff once you’re out of school
and they help get you jobs and that also connect
you.
So in 2012 I was with a writer/producer friend,
we were working on this for a teen conspiracy
thriller and it took place in Napa.
And while it was being written I was producing
a fake trailer to help pitch it, to help show
what the movie would look and feel like.
And half of it…no probably a quarter of
it was like a so-called script-o-matic, so
we would rip shots from existing movies.
So then the other 70% we would actually shoot,
we got locations and hired actors, we wrote
the script for a trailer.
We went out and shot those elements and cut
it all together, color-timed it so it’s
all very consistent, had it mixed at a friend’s
post-production house.
And so we had a trailer that looked…a lot
of people were actually confused.
They thought this was a movie that had already
gotten made.
Also one of the actresses in the film was
Aimee Teegarden.
Before she became a well-known actress she
was actually the lead actress in my thesis
film at USC.
So that’s how she and I met and became friends.
So she agreed to be in this trailer just because
people recognize her.
So when the trailer was sent out we got a
little bit more attention than we would if
she wasn’t in it.
So one of my friends from USC was friends
with a manager.
He sent this manager the trailer, they’re
like “this looks like someone we can get
made” and that’s how I got my first manager.
And that’s also how I met the writer who
wrote DANGER ONE Steffen because they were
managing him at the same time too.
So even though that teen conspiracy thriller
never got made it eventually got to DANGER
ONE getting made just because it introduced
Steffen and we became friends and realized
we worked together well.